hello Samantha
hello okay thank you how can we help you
today yes sir it can be really quick I
don't - given to it because I know I
need to run that gluten-free diet by
it's pretty hard but my neck cracking I
spoke to you about it here in Sugar Land
when he visited the last time and I'm
asking is for my bodyweight should I
wait able to collect all of the
necessary packs before I begin cookie I
want to get the best benefit of it you
know so my anyway what wish you wait
I'll wait 108-178 on five one zero five
one you should weigh about 110 I have
one I have one healthy brain an art pack
right now and I have two CDs for
diabetes but I haven't cooking it
because I want to wait until I cannot
you know get more of them you know I'm
saying I don't know I would get going
right away you want to get rid of bad
food start immediately and then that's
gonna save you some money in addition to
the one one healthy start pack I think
she said here charmagne what would you
give Samantha to deal was it cracking
neck I would give her some gel well
there you go okay so I Charmaine's
exactly correct even if you only can do
half I would go ahead I wouldn't wait
and you know wait a month I wouldn't do
that
I'd start even if you can only do half
in addition to the Healthy Start pact
char's quite correct ideally you would
get two bottles of the vitamin d three
capsules or the spray citrus spray if
three spritzes at breakfast and threes
for instance at dinner time or three
capsules of breakfast for you cancel
dinner time if you can only do half I
would go ahead with that and then also
let's see here what would you do to
support and promote main us repair
cartilage and ligaments and tendons
two discs between vertebrae all that
kind of stuff Charmaine well yep the
gluco gel and ideally your body weight
you take 15 a day you weigh about 110
pounds sure how many gluco gel do you
take a day I think 12 commitments yeah
12 a day for maintenance the only way
810 pounds 170 pounds you need 15 and so
if you can only do six or eight it's
better than nothing you want to get
started as quickly as possible you say
don't have a fracture or something like
that
okay so answer that question question
number two okay and because I was taking
care of sick parents until I found out
about you and now everybody's getting
better thank God but my question to you
is what would be the first thing you do
to be more successful for me you know
like I since I didn't go to copy the
first thing I should do to get myself
okay we have a lot of people who are
ninth grade dropouts who do extremely
well in this business you don't need to
be a college graduate to do this
business as long as you can read fifth
grade reading level and can count to ten
you're okay there we we have like I say
we have literally hundreds and hundreds
of people who are high school dropouts
or high school graduates who do
extremely well in this business because
everybody wants health everybody needs
health and so forth
Shar do you have any medical training or
any college or anything absolutely not
oh no Community College even nope okay
nothing online you didn't get any
certificates online for any college
studies well I just took a course in
welding you took a course in welding was
that in high school okay and so you took
a course in welding I know your dad was
in construction so you wanted to work
with your dad so here
Samantha Shar is is it as a high school
graduate no health courses no science
courses none of that kind of stuff